all right
yes
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen this
is the staff in
the supreme media
could you remain
outstanding please for the
council prayer
almighty god grant to us
all
needed guidance
all needed guidance wisdom and judgment
as we face the tasks before us
and enable us now and always
to worthily discharge the sacred trust
placed by the people in our hands
amen
thank you
[Music]
declarations of interest
being none
public forum
submissions here
no thank you
we've got major late items 4.1
decision on the city block investment
the reason that this item is not on the
agenda
is that it
was not really in time for the
agenda being published
reasons why
the discussion of the item cannot be
delayed
and matters can progress in a timely
manner where should pod move it be
accepted as a late item
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the virgil in favor say aye hi
minutes of the
council held on the 21st of december
2021 to be confirmed
[Music]
good
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carrie
be moved at the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the
infrastructural services committee be
held held on the 21st of december be
received
moved
the secretary
moved in seconded discussion questions
put it to the boat all in favor say aye
aye against carried
the minutes of the extraordinary meeting
of the performance policy and
partnerships committee
out on the 21st of december 2021 be
received i'll move though received your
worship
second
moved and seconded new discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say i i
i
carried
the minutes of the extraordinary meeting
of the risk insurance committee
out on the 21st of december
2021 be received
i'll move those your worship
thank you
second that
i was present you wish i'm not part of
the met of the committee but i would
second those thank you
thank you i'll put it to the vote all in
favor say aye aye
against carried
the minutes of infrastructural services
committee held on the 1st of february
2022
be received
read those
moved
second second
discussion questions
put it to the vote all and further say
aye
aye against carriage
that the minutes of the performance
policy partnerships committee
out on the 8th of february 2022 be
received you worship i'll move that
those are received
seconded
you
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
all right
it's carried
moved at the minutes of the bluff
community board meeting held on the 14th
of february 2022 be received i'll move
that they received your worship although
i was absent at the time
oh secondly
thank you
moved and seconded
discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
hi
move the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting of the performance policy
partnerships committee at the 17th of
february 2022 we received
i'll move those you worship
thank you
second though is your worship moved and
seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
report of the mayor
i'll move
the report is our unique steps for the
city block decision
maybe some officers who could take us
through that report
we should we just need to
move the receipt off your report
okay
i'll move the
receipt of the
mirrors report it's broken up into
sections
so that
it's hopefully easier to read
i'll second that
it's moved and seconded
discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carriage
now the city decision on the city block
yeshua ship
mitsuta is on the
zoo
and hayden powell is here to introduce
the report
good afternoon worship councillors
report should be here with you now uh
knowledge it was a late item uh nothing
really further to add
uh we're we're all here sort of in the
mornings for that discussion so open up
open it up to any questions you may have
of myself rhiannon or
other officers
you worship to get it on the table i'm
happy to
move the
recommendations as they um said in the
report confirm them
happy to second those your worship
you've been seconded any discussion
was of course lengthy discussion at the
previous meeting this morning
and
seemed to be general consensus
counselor anderson
um so today he's got his hand up but
after he's spoken i'm happy to
come
thank you through yourself in worship
there was a question raised at ppp in
relation to
cost per rate payer in relation to the
city block i just wanted to clarify
that the city block is
um
we the original funding via city block
is through ichl now which means that we
are doing that via
through the dividend side of it so it's
not an impact on the ratepayers
and the latest funding
component within the
city block
is uh via a borrowing
arrangement and therefore is
charged through and that will come
through via the rentals in relation to
that so it doesn't have an impact on the
rate powers as well
but as an indication of
for the councillors in relation to
debt
percentages
decided to also give you as is an extra
what the cost of uh 10 million worth of
borrowing is so that councillors are
aware of that
the rough
cost on
for ratepayers and this is the average
rate power so the average house
it changes for everyone it's roughly
around 19 per annum for about 10 million
dollars
worth of debt so i just wanted to give
that to council so to put it into
perspective as well
thank you thank you
do you need a resolution to
thank you any discussion counselor
edmondson
thanks um i'm not going to reiterate
what i talked about this morning with
all of the risks that have been realized
throughout the process of this
project since 2015-16
but i think it is just important to
always acknowledge that the role of us
as councillors and elected members is to
question and challenge the information
we are given um and also to make sure
that we go into our decision making with
our eyes wide open
and i think that's a really important
part when i think back to all of the
risks that have been realized through
this process some of the times we've
gone oh i didn't know that might happen
when we had actually been told that
those risks were there but we'd chosen
to
um to to to
not see them for the good of the project
and i think even though this might be a
great project for the city um and have
great outcomes um down the track there's
still risks and we have to make sure
that we acknowledge those risks know
that that might mean that we have to
sacrifice some other things going into
the future because of those risks
and make our decisions accordingly
thank you
thanks for the navi
um three you chaired two issues i guess
um this is the second time from my
colleague today that i've heard the
statement that she has some reservations
about the risks involved with the uh
um with the city block but it's my
understanding that a majority if not a
significant majority of councillors at
the time have worked their way through
in the last year or year and a half
the risks that we have at the at the
city block
and certainly
the risks that we would potentially face
with the withdrawal of one of those
significant funders so i just wanted to
reflect on that
and and just reflect on the comment you
made your worship that there was general
consensus this morning um i was opposed
to the acceptance of the
um
two of the
recommendations today because i felt
that we shouldn't have
accepted the 13.6 million dollars until
we had a clearer pitching back from our
finance people
on the um
investment portfolios that we have and
and how they might impact on
funding the extra money that was
required
thank you
yes it is
bit repetitive but
again i felt that
we can't stop now we've just got to make
this project work
and
it's
going to
be challenging
but
we just have to
forge ahead
and
all projects are
that are on the scale
those challenges especially in the area
that we're living through at the moment
so it's onward and awkward
and i believe it'll be
a great asset to the city
it's so i know it sounds
pickled but
when
some of the surveys i've looked at show
that shopping
is
people's number one recreational pursuit
and
it's just
uh
effect of life
any further discussion
questions
put it to the virtual and forever say
aye
aye
against
aries
any urgent business
leader
now urgent business
move on to public excluded session
i'll move that way your worship with the
exception of mr mckenzie
to remain as the external governance
thank you for appointee that
any discussion questions
put to the vote or don't try to say hi
hi
it's carried
thank you for your attendance